اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم في ملفاتنا لهذا المساء
اعلانوناو ارسال مساعدات لاوكرانيا منوره
للاستهلاك الدولي ام تحول في سياسات بلاده
تجاه روسيا
توسيع القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه في
الفلبين هل يؤدي لاشعال الاوضاع مع الصين
ان يساعد في استقرار منطقه شرق اسيا
وملفات جديده تفتح ضد بايدن اهمها كورونا
وملف المهاجرين فهل ما زال الهدف هو عزل
الرئيس ام تبني استراتيجيه جديده تقوم على
اغراقه في معارك جانبيه
هل تخلت تل ابيب عن حيادها بشان الحرب في
اوكرانيا لعل هذا هو السؤال الابرز بعد
اعلان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو في مقابله مع شبكه سينانا
الامريكيه بعد اعلانه ان اسرائيل تدرس
ارساله مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا
نتنياهو خلال المقابله لم يقدم اي تعهدات
جازمه لاوكرانيا خاصه ان بلاده حافظت على
علاقاتها مع روسيا لكنه مشاهدينا اكد ان
الولايات المتحده نقلت مخزونا من ذخيره
المدفعيه المخصصه لاسرائيل الى اوكرانيا
واضاف نتنياهو انه طلب منه او طلب منه
التوسط بشكل غير رسمي في النزاع بعد عمليه
روسيا في اوكرانيا لكنه لم يتابع ذلك لانه
كان حينها في صفوف المعارضه ولفت الى انه
مستعد للاعبي دور الوسيط في حال طلب منه
وذلك اضافه الى الولايات
وعلى الفور ردت روسيا على هذه التصريحات
وهددت اسرائيل برد عسكري انتقامي في حاله
تسليمها اسلحه الى اوكرانيا وقالت الناطقه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا قالت ان على
كل الدول التي تسلم اسلحه يجب ان تفهم
اننا سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهدافا مشروعه
للقوات الروسيه
العلاقات الروسيه الاسرائيليه بدات
بالتوتر مع بدء الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
فبراير الماضي تصريحات اسرائيليه الاثارت
حفيظه موسكو انعكس التوتر بشكل واضح ليس
فقط على مستوى التصريحات وانما اجراءات
اتخذت على الارض بين البلدين ملفات وقضايا
معلقه معلنه هو غير معلنه روسيا اغلقت
اواخر العاب الماضي وكاله يهوديه تساعد
على الهجره الى اسرائيل
لانتهاكها القوارب القرار الروسي اثار
حفيظه اسرائيل
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
السابق اهلا بك من القدس يوني بن مناحيم
المحلله السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من موسكو ومعك سيد
تصريحات بنيامين نتنياهو
بقوله بانه يدرس رساله اسلحه هو قال القبه
الحديديه واسلحه اخرى كذلك لاوكرانيا هل
هذه التصريحات تكتيكيه استراتيجيه هل هي
مناوره
لخدمه ملفات ام ان هناك تغييرا في الموقف
الاسرائيلي
هذا ليست علاقات تكتيكيه او محاوله يلجا
من ضغوطات الامريكيه هذا السياسه
اسرائيليه من بدايه الازمه في اوكرانيا
منذ سنه اولا هناك في روسيا ليست هناك اي
تساؤلات وجود او عدم وجود القوات المسلحه
اسرائيليه في صفوف جيش اوكراني هذا الصوره
واضحه تماما وتاكيد على ما هو انا لقولي
هذا انا انقل الى الى تصريحه لان في اذاعه
في اسرائيل
الذي كانت ياخذ
مياح التصريح من احد القاده
القوات اوكرانيه في بخموت اليوم وهو اسمه
اسكولتس ماغر جيفسكي
الذي هو كان يتقدم امام شاشه التلفزيون
واذاعه اوكرانيا اسرائيليه على اساس انه
هو دابت القوات الخاصه جيش اسرائيل
وفي 30 شهر الماضي انا
صدفه ما كنتم استدمتم مع التسريخ اخر وهذا
هو الدينيس دينيس
جيستنيك الذي هو قائد الكتيبه الاوكرانيه
وهو يتقدم امام التلفزيون
الاوكرانييني وهي حقول ان انا دابت قوات
مسلحه اسرائيليه لذلك هم يشرحونه الان
الموضوع اكبر من موضوع دراسه ارسال
الاسلحه حضرتك تتحدث على حضور قوات حضور
قاده مستشارين في اوكرانيا
منذ زمان
ما رايك في هذه النقطه هل اسرائيل صامته
على موضوع حضور قياداتها العسكريه في داخل
الاوكراني
ليس هناك اي قائد
اسرائيلي في الجيش الاوكراني من الجيش
النظامي انا اعتقد بان الضيف من موسكو
يتحدث عن ناس قدموا في الجيش الاسرائيلي
وبالماضي
وهم جنود احتياط وهما احرار تركوا اسرائيل
ونقلوا الى لوكينا لكي يشاركوا في الحاء
ولكن هم ليس في مهمه رسميه من اسرائيل ولا
اسرائيل ليس اي علاقه فيه ولكن ضيف يقول
لك بانه يقدر نفسه على انه قائد عسكري
وقائد لكتيبه كامله يعني غدا يظهر انسان
في التلفزيون ويدعي بانه رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي ذلك
طيب سيد جوني وكان
اسرائيل بين فكيه كماشى وكانها بين امريكا
حليفتها والتي تمدها بالمساعدات التي تقدر
بمليارات الدولارات في الواقع ضمن اتفاق
سنوي طويل الامد وبين روسيا كذلك التي
تجمعها بها مصالح امنيه واستراتيجيه وخاصه
على الارض السوريه اين تقف اسرائيل من
هذين الحليفين
اسرائيل لن تغير
السياساتها وهي
تحافظ العلاقات معك غير ومع روسيا وروسيا
هي صديقه اسرائيل والكل وهذا ليس الصيغ
بان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين التنياهو لك لو
علاقات خاصه
وعلاقات صداقه مع الرئيس بوتين
ولذلك نتنياهو لن يعمل اي شيء قد يدور
العلاقات بين اسرائيل وبين روسيا يعني
صديق يعني تقول بان بوتين صديق لبنيامين
نتنياهو وسيزود الاوكران بالاسلحه ما
تعليقك
يعني لا تاخذني بس انا اضحك اولا ان
الصداقه في امور الدوليه ليست انا لا اعرف
هذا عباره لا يمكن لان هناك مساله مصالح
روسيه اسرائيليه عربيه امريكيه اوروبيه
لذلك اذا نحن نتناول
علاقات بين الانسان والانسان شيء ممكن ان
يكون علاقات الصداقه بين الرئيس الدوله
والرئيس الوزراء الدوله اخرى لا يمكن ان
يكونوا اي نوع من الصداقه هذا الصداقه هذا
اهمال مصالح القوميه يا للروسيه
ولكن ما الذي تريد قوله تريد القول بان
اسرائيل اتخذت طرفا لتدعم
اولا في روسيا انا اقول لكم بصراحه
ولزميلي انا في القدس انه في روسيا بين
خبراء العسكريين
لهم وزن في مجتمع
سياسي التحليلي في روسيا
في
نشرها في انترنت
مقاله طويل تحليلي تقول الا انه في
اوكرانيا في خلال هذا حرب الجاريه يحلل
يحل مشكله ليست امريكيه وروسيه اما هناك
مصلحه اسرائيليه مباشره
ويتحدثون انه هناك ليست فقط شخصيه بين
جنسيه يهوديه بينزلنسكي رئيس وزراء رئيس
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه واسرائيل ولدي
بدا واحد تل ابيب ليش هذا موضوع موضوع
اهدافه سياسيه
ممكن ان هناك مشكله
طيب خليني ندخل في جوهر الدوله
الاسرائيليه الثانيه في ارض كرينيه
وفي قرن بشكل خاص
صحيح انه الموضوع الرئيسي هو موضوع مصالح
كما قال الضيف من موسكو
وهناك مصلحه اسرائيليه وصيه مشتركه للحفاظ
على العلاقات بين الدولتين
ونتنياه ولن ينوي تغيير هذه العلاقه
وبالاضافه الى المصالح في كمان في ايضا
اسمح لي فقط لانه ضيفي لا يقول ذلك هو
يقول بانه هناك طموح اسرائيلي
بتمركز بشكل او باخر في اوكرانيا
هناك مصالح هناك مصالح اكبر من مصالحه هذا
غير صحيح اطلاقا واسرائيل ليس لا اي
طموحات في اوقرينا وليس هناك اي شيء من
هذا نور يعني كل انسان يستطيع ان ينشر
مقالات ويكتب تحليلات ولكن انا اقول لك من
مصادر غوليا ان هذا ليس صحيح طيب سعيد متى
اذا افترضنا بان اسرائيل ستعتمد هذه
الفكره بعد الدراسه وستزود اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه كيف سيؤثر ذلك على المصالح
الاستراتيجيه الامنيه على الشراكه الروسيه
الاسرائيليه في سوريا مثلا
اولا ان في سوريا او في اوكرانيا نحن
استخدمنا مع موقف الغربي موقف الدول
الغربيه مجموعه الدول الغربيه واسرائيل
ضمن هذه المجموعه من البدايه الازمه ونحن
نفهم هذا جيدا واي احقويل اي احاديث ان
روسيا في علاقات خاصه مع اسرائيل هذا ليست
علاقات عاطفيه علاقات سياسيه علاقات مبنيه
على المشرحه ولذلك اذا نحن اليوم
نسمع اصوات عن امكانيه تزويد السلاح
الاسرائيلي سلاحي اللي موجود اليوم في ارض
اوكرانيه وفي اليد قوات مسلحه هؤلاء
الضباط القوات الخاصه اسرائيليه وهذا هو
موجود في الانترنت يمكن ان توجد هذا بكل
سهوله ليس هذا مشكل مثلا القبه الحديديه
في اوكرانيا
اقل لم تتحدث اخبار على رصدها فدخل
الاوكرانيين نتنياهو يقول بانه يدرس
امكانيه ارسال القبه الحديديه الى
اوكرانيا
انا سمعت اليوم
من خبير العسكري جنرال الجيش اوكرانييني
الذي قوه كان هو يتناول هذا الموضوع هو
سابقا كان النائب الرئيس
اركان الحرب اوكرانيا جيش اوكرانيا وتحدث
امام احد التلفزيونات او كريمي وقال ان
قبعه حديديه هذا يمكن ان تصلح فقط
لاسرائيل في اوكرانيا لا يمكن ان تصلحوا
اي شيء
لجيش اوكرانيين لا يمكن ان اوكرانيا جيش
اوكرانيا ان يستعمل اوني اعتمد في دفاع
جوي على
الاجهزه
الاسرائيليه السبب واحد ان هذا مسافه
الاسرائيليين اقل بكثير
والمواجهه تلك
حدي ضد الصواريخ فلسطينيه ضد من كازا من
امكانيه مين
لبنان من حزب الله او من سوريا
خلينا نقدم شويه
هذا شيء اخر وضحت الفكره بانه لن تكون
مفيده بحسب بعض الخبراء العسكريين كما
يقراون سيد جوني منذ قليل قلت لي بانه
اسرائيل تعتمد منذ زمن
خطط الحياد ولكن هذه المره جاءت تصريحات
بلينكن للضغط كذلك على الجانب الاسرائيلي
للضغط على نتنياهو لتمكين اوكرانيا من
السلاح وبالتالي هل ستستجيب حكومه نتنياهو
لهذه المطالب
ما اعتقدش انا لا اعتقد ذلك هناك ضغط ضغط
امريكي صحيح ولكن هو صامت في هذا الخصوص
وهو لن يعمل اي شيء يدور بالعلاقات
الاسرائيليه الروسيه اولا بسبب المصالح
المشتركه والسبب الثاني كما قلت علاقته مع
الرئيس بوتين
ولذلك استخدم اللغه
ولكن لم يفعل ذلك لماذا يصرح الجواب تفضل
لو سمحت شكرا اليك
واستخدم اللغه الدبلوماسيه بالمقابله للسي
ان ولكن هو لم يوافق ولن يؤكد بانه
سيزود بالسلاح وقال لنا ادرس هذه
الامكانيه ليس اكثر من ذلك تفضلي ولكن حتى
حديثه عن امكانيه دراسه هذه المطالب يفتح
الباب لتاويلات هو لم يقل بانه نحن سنعتمد
موقف الحياه كما اعتمدناه في السنوات
الاخيره هو قال سادرس وهذا الموضوع فتح
المجال للجدل وانا سؤالي لما ياتي ضغط من
بلينكن هل ستستجيب قلت لي بانها لن تستجيب
طيب لماذا يصرح اذا
هذه اللغه الدبلوماسيه وهو لا يريد ان
يدور العلاقات معين ايضا ولذلك
الموضوع مفتوح ولكن
هل تغيرت المعادله تعتقد هل حرب روسيا
اوكرانيا يمكن ان تلقي بظلالها على
تغيرات جيوسياسيه او استفاد جديده فيما
يخص مناطق اخرى بقاع اخرى
تشهد الشباكات تحدثنا عن روسيا ولكن
المشاركه الاسرائيليه الروسيه ممتده
ومستمره منذ فتره طويله هل يمكن ان تختلف
المعادله بهذه التصريحات
ذكرتي امر مهيمن للغايه هذا الصراع في
اوكرانيا ليس هذا الصراع الاقليمي صراع
بين روسيا واوكرانيا بين جيش اوكرانيا
قوات الروسيه اما هذا
النشره الصحيحه
هذا كل الكره الارضيه في تحريك
لذلك كل هذه التغيرات تيك توك يعني كل
القارات تتحرك ليست هذا منطقه واحده
اسرائيل لا شك انا اوافق مع زميلي انا في
القدس لماذا لان
نتنياهو عنده شعور كالانسان ولكن ليست هو
الان ياخذ القرار قرار ياخذ فوق الراس
نتنياهو وفوق الراس ممكن
بايدن ولذلك التحركات الان في
قرى ارضيه على السياسيا هي مرتبطه مع
مشاريع اخرى قوه الاعلاميه
السلطه العالميه الجديده والعرب يعرفون
هذا جيدا قلت بان من يتخذ القرار يقف او
يتموضع على راسه نتنياهو على راس بيض من
اولا ان هناك
تحركات الذي تدمرت الاتحاد السوفيتي اولا
هناك محاوله تدمير وازاله الدوله الروسيه
حاليا وهناك حتى انشقاقات في داخل دوله
الامريكيه بين ترامب وبايرن وهذا قوه الذي
تحاول من بدايه البدايات ان يبنى
السلطه العالميه سلطه
كما يقولون الحكومه العمق وهي في امريكا
في روسيا في كل الدول العالم عرب استاد
ممثل هذا القوه يفهمون هذه اغتياله صدام
حسين منذ عشرين سنه
واغتيال مؤمر
في اليمن وحرف سوريا
ومحاوله انقلاب في مصر لازاله
وكذلك كل هذه التحركات هذا الدليل على ان
عالمنا نحن في تحرك ولا شارك ان روسيا
تفهم هذا جيدا واستانت تجد من الاوضاع انا
سنوات العاشره الاخيره في العالم العربي
واستنتاج واضح تماما نتيجه هذا الاستنتاج
ارسل بوتين قواتها المصالحه لاوكرانيا لكي
يمنع يستفيدوا تلك القوه الاخرى
واوكرانيا وثانيه ان يهددوا امن الكوميدي
كوفي
السابق من القدس يوني بن مناحيم المحلل
السياسي شكرا لكم